-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
Guys, let's get to some really,
really important news.
Yeah. I read that
due to a seed shortage,
mustard could be in short supply
this summer.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Yeah.
Luckily, every parent still has
a barrel in the fridge
that they bought from Costco
in 1997.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna be alright.
That's right, a mustard shortage
is happening.
Apparently, all supermarkets are
down to only 5,000 options.
That's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell things are bad.
Today, President Biden called
Emmanuel Macron like,
"Pardon me, would you have
any Grey Poupon?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there's a shortage of
mustard seeds.
Then French's was like,
"Thank God we make ours
from plutonium, so..."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys hear about this?
Toyota is recalling all of their
new electric S.U.V.s because
there's a risk that all --
the wheels are falling off
while being driven.
[ Laughter ]
Toyota told the owners, "Drop
off your car to be fixed."
And the owners are like, "Uh,
how about, can you come to us?
[ Laughter ]
"I mean, we have no wheels."
Right now, there's a Toyota
factory worker who's like,
"Oh, that's what those
50,000 bolts are for.
I'm an idiot. I'm sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this.
FedEx announced that they will
start taking photographs of
customers' packages to prove
that they were delivered.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah.
In fact, they even released
this commercial.
Watch this.
-We here at FedEx know
your packages are important,
so we're taking photographs
to prove
they were delivered on time...
[ Laughter ]
...when scheduled...
...and with the utmost care.
[ Laughter ]
FedEx, nothin' but net.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
That last one had good aim.
-That last one was great.
-Yeah. Whoever that was
was good, yeah.
Switching gears, there's
a new documentary coming out
about January 6th that has
exclusive interviews
with former president Trump,
and they just released
the first footage.
Let's take a look.
-I don't think you want to have
the water in the picture, right?
You can take it out.
You know what you can do, Nick?
Put the table back, and put the
water on the table
without the thing on top of it.
Go ahead. Take it out.
Yeah.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Right, let's go.
-Riveting.
[ Laughter ]
People were like, "Forget
January 6th, just give me
12 more hours of what happened
to that table."
[ Laughter ]
[ as Trump ]
The table isn't working.
Get Rudy Giuliani to get on
all fours
and then balance the water on
his head."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] As I mentioned
before, YouTube has
a new feature where you can skip
the boring parts of a video
and cut right to the good part.
And I guess they have something
similar on TikTok as well.
We tried it out with some recent
videos people have posted.
For instance, if you're watching
a video, you can skip this part.
-Whee!
Whee!
-Yeah. And go right to this.
-Whe--
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Ow!
-Let me give you
another example.
[ Laughter ]
Let me give you another example.
You can skip this part.
[ Bell tolls ]
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
And go right to this.
[ Bell tolls ]
[ Audience ohs ]
She missed, she missed,
she missed.
Maybe one more final example.
-One more.
-Yeah, one example.
You can skip this part.
[ Both scream ]
And go right to this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Swa-- Swallowed his necklace.
[ Laughter ]
Going upside down.
Yeah, he swallowed his necklace.
[ Imitates choking ]
Oh, man, he's good.
He's alright.
Hey, guys, I saw that Netflix
officially confirmed
that they are going to add
a cheaper version
of their service that has ads.
Yep.
[ Audience boos ]
[ Laughter ]
A cheaper Netflix with ads, yep.
And they're going to
call it Hulu.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, listen to this.
Amazon just announced that
they're working on a new feature
that lets Alexa speak
in anyone's voice.
[ Audience oohs ]
You just give it
some reference audio,
and then it can impersonate
your voice.
I think it's pretty cool.
Let's check it out.
Hey, Alexa.
-How can I help you?
-Alexa, speak to me in the voice
of Jimmy Fallon.
-[ Masculine voice ] Okay.
Now, I am Jimmy Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, that's your -- that's
your impression of me?
-Yes. Hey, Guys.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
I host "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
[ Laughter ]
-That's not a very good
impression.
-Wrong. I sound just like you.
Everyone, give it up for
the Roots.
-No, I d--
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do not sound like that.
-Yes, you do. I'm Jimmy Fallon.
My favorite place is my desk.
I have a mug on my desk.
I love my desk and my mug.
-I mean, you do say that a lot.
-I do not.
-Higgins gets what I am
talking about.
-Fine, Alexa, speak to me in
the voice of Steve Higgins.
-[ as Jimmy Fallon ] Hi, Jimmy.
It's me, Steve Higgins.
How can I help you?
-That -- That sounds
just like me.
-[ Masculine voice ] No.
That was my impression of
Steve Higgins.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
-Okay, good, I think this needs
more work.
Let's move on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some big sports news --
tonight was the NBA draft
over at the Barclays Center
in Brooklyn.
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah, what a night.
In 20 years, we'll be able to
look back
and say that suit
did not age well.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
The draft is exciting.
For two hours, NBA commissioner
Adam Silver announces the picks
and then flies back
to his home planet.
It's really -- It's great.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you got to love
the NBA draft.
It's the one night a year where
a 20-year-old genuinely says,
"Yes, I get to move to
Sacramento."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, well, this is wild.
Guys, Billie Eilish revealed
that she sent a body double
out on stage in her place at
the start of her Coachella set,
and no one noticed.
That's pretty crazy.
Right, Tariq?
-Yeah, Jimmy.
That's some pretty wild stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-Higgins, notice anything
different about Tariq?
-Uh, no. Looks like the same old
Tariq to me, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Quest, I think some people are
using body doubles.
-Yeah, I mean, that's kind of
unprofessional.
You're right. Yeah.
-I agree. Well.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In other news...
[ Applause ]
...I saw that a Swedish man
broke a world record
by throwing a washing machine
more than 14 feet.
Yeah, the name of the record he
broke was World's Weirdest Man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the stuff!
That's the stuff right there,
Fallon!
[ Laughter ]
-Calm down, sir.
-Where'd he get the popcorn?
-I don't know.
He's not even wearing a mask.
-[ Laughing ]
He's not wearing a mask.
-Sir, please calm down.
"That's the stuff"?
-That's the stuff, man.
Come on, that's the stuff.
-Guys, I read there's
a rail-worker strike
in the U.K. right now,
and one man who always rides
the train has beaten the strike
by paddling to work in
an inflatable kayak.
Here he is.
Yeah.
If you thought the guy who biked
to work was insufferable,
imagine this guy.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is fun, guys.
A Star Wars fan just spent
$2.3 million
on a model of an X-Wing fighter.
Yeah, when the buyer told
his wife, she said,
"Congrats, you now have
two exes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on, that's the stuff.
Fore!
-Finally
"Thor: Love and Thunder"
is almost in theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
I'm excited.
And ahead of the release,
we thought that we'd share
some fun facts about Marvel's
famous God of Thunder.
This is
"Thor: Little Known Facts."
-♪ Thor ♪
♪ Little known facts ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
But first, I'm going to need
someone to help me.
His new movie
"Thor: Love and Thunder"
is in theaters on July 8th.
Please welcome Chris Hemsworth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello.
-Chris!
-How you doing?
-How are you, bud?
-I'm very well, mate. Very well.
-Thank you so much
for doing this.
Chris, our researchers found
some interesting facts
about Thor to help fans get
ready for the big premiere.
-Of course they did, Jimmy.
I was very impressed with what
you guys found.
This stuff -- it's stuff that I
didn't even know.
Only hard-core comic book fans
do, so it's very exciting.
-I think our research team
did a great job.
Let's get started with some
little-know facts about Thor.
Here we go, I'll go first.
Did you know that Thor's father
is Odin, but his godfather
is actually
Sean "P. Diddy" Combs.
[ Laughter ]
-It's true. It's true.
It's actually the plot
of this film.
So we shouldn't say too much
about it.
-No spoilers, yeah.
Why don't you give me one?
-Asgardians prolong their lives
by eating
the Golden Apples of Idunn.
The Asgardians learned of the
apples in an article on Goop.
-Wow.
I didn't know they had Goop.
-Gwyneth Paltrow linked it.
-Yeah, I love those articles.
How about this one?
Thor's full name is actually
Courtney Thorne Smith.
Did you know that?
-Can you believe it?
-Yeah.
These are all fascinating.
-In this one, Thor has to get a
job because he lost all of his
money on "Thored Ape" NFTs.
-Oh, it's tough.
-He's a big metaverse guy.
-It's a tough market right now.
How about this one?
Everyone knows Chris Hemsworth's
brothers Liam and Luke,
but he also has a fourth brother
named Clemsworth Hemsworth.
He plays bass with
the Jonas Brothers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Clemsworth, he's a guy.
-He's good.
Talented, talented,
talented guy.
Why don't you give me one?
-Thor's hammer is named Mjolnir.
His belt is named is Megingjord.
And his pecks are named
Bert and Ernie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go.
That's what I'm talking about.
My thanks to Chris Hemsworth.
His new movie "Thor: Love and
Thunder" is out July 8th.
Thank you, buddy.
Always good to see you.
-You too. Thank you.
-He's the greatest.